there's only the award for art direction
are two of this year's nominees in the
best acting category [ __ ] Spacek
and Peter O'Toole
in making films everything begins on
paper I'm sure you all know that the
script does and the music does but so do
the contributions of the art director
one of the joys for filmmakers of all
sorts is a good set and an art director
needs must be a meld of architect and
magician for he may be required to
provide ad hoc and spontaneously a
Chinese restaurant in the middle of a
Judean wilderness so one forgives him
precipitous staircases for his true
workbench is the fabled drawing board to
which he returns hundreds and hundreds
of times and produces designs from which
the final picture gets it's particular
environment we'd like to take you behind
the scenes and show you some of the
original sketches and drawings by this
year's nominees for best achievement in
art direction
the nominees are coal miners daughter
art direction by John W Corso set
decoration by John M Dwyer
the Elephant Man art direction by
Stewart Craig and Bob Cartwright
set direction by Hugh skate the Empire
Strikes Back art direction by Norman
Reynolds Leslie dilly Harry Lange and
Alan Tompkins set decoration by Michael
Ford
Kagemusha art direction by Yashiro
moeraki and the winners are
pierre good bra and Jack Stevens
protects
it's basic and I pretty now just said my
friend Thiago far doesn't speak English
so I will just say thank you twice in
English
the real non-conductive committee
offered us to be back inside